I remember coming back to Sweden and
telling my friends getting a job in
Hollywood has walk in the park it's so
easy you just show up and Ben Stiller's
there and you read a couple of lines
they fly you business class and they
sent a guy to the airport with a sign
with your name on it reality hit me when
I landed and it took me three years to
find my next job
Zoolander that was my first job in the
United States it was two years into my
career and I was doing a play in
Stockholm at the time and I obviously
didn't have representation or anything
in the States and was there hanging out
with my family and and my father's
manager just asked like what would you
want to kissing you out to an audition
if you want if you think that'd be fun
and I thought why not I'm here and
that'd be a great story to tell my
friends back home so I went and it was
for this movie called Zoolander I read a
scene and went home and thought that was
it and they called me back and wanted me
to come in and meet with Ben and read
whether it was Ben Stiller
so I did that and then they called us
and you got the job and a week later
they flew me business class to New York
City and I got to shoot with with Ben
Stiller and one thought was incredible
and not only Ben by the other guys were
so cool and went rogue down Broadway in
that Jeep if you remember singing like
wake me up the Wham song just being
goofy and stupid and it was like I
couldn't believe my luck like I get to
do this and they're actually paying me
for this
this is stupid if you see the movie I'm
in it for like three seconds and dying a
gasoline fire or a tragic death
for me it was obviously a profound
experience and quite different from
working on a small stage in Stockholm I
was vaguely familiar with that world
that doesn't I wouldn't call myself a
model but I was I'd done a little bit of
it and yeah I know I did that I loved it
melancholia there are a couple of times
where I've just basically said yes
before you go reading when I heard that
Lars wanted me in this film I said yes
and I told my agent I don't care what
else is out there I'm gonna go to Sweden
and do this the movie is about the end
of the earth and it was one of the most
lively and fun sets they've ever been on
most people expect it to be more
authoritarian that he'd be more of a
tyrant on set and that would be more
tension on set and it's just like the
polar opposite of that everyone felt so
liberated the way he shoots is I
remember the first day I had a scene
with Kirsten Dunst and we're not in a
stretch limo on our way on the way to
our wedding and it's scripted but it's
also quite loosely scripted so he gave
us the kind of the run now and talked us
through the scene but he wanted some
improvisation and then he said it at a
certain point Alex the car is stuck on
this road and a certain asar weren't
maybe you step out to help the driver
from from outside the vehicle and I
asked the will so which side would you
prefer cuz with more traditional
filmmaking the director has a plan well
I'm gonna shoot the master from this
side so it's good if you come out here
because then I see you if you're on the
other side I won't see you and you just
looked perplexed and he was like well I
don't know whatever you feel like doing
and do what you've got to do and then
I'll follow you and again we had some of
the finest actors in the world John Hurt
and Charlotte Rampling it was he sick
you know extraordinary actors it felt
like everyone turned into a little kid
because everyone like was so excited
about the freedom and the sense of trust
that he would instill in all this just
his mode of operation was basically just
do your thing and I'll find you but they
don't come in and whisper something can
you do this can you say that way or can
you pick up the postcard when she looks
down
like it can be very specific it's not
like he's like oh do your thing I'm just
gonna sit here and drink my cappuccino
like he knows exactly what he wants one
second be on the other side of the
ballroom with two hundred extras and
then the next second he's in your face
with a camera and find something you
know it's it was so wonderful and the
first time I got to work with my dad as
well he plays my my best man on and at
my wedding a real douchebag
the character not my father
Generation Kill I was having a hard time
professionally in oh six oh seven
because again I was quite disillusioned
by the hubris I had after Zoolander
thinking like oh I'll just fly over to
LA and booked another great job I rarely
got to read anything I was excited about
and if I ever found something that had
some substance or a rolled that was
interesting to me a big-name actor would
come in because great roles are far and
few between then Generation Kill came up
in no 7 and this was by David Simon and
Ed Burns who created the wire it's based
on a couple of articles from Rolling
Stone magazine by Evan Wright that he
then expanded into a book and I thought
it was just the most riveting story ever
the character of Brad Kolbert Iceman was
I was just a dream role I was certain
that I wouldn't get it because it was
too good but audition a couple of times
and fortunately for me they didn't want
a big-name actors they wanted to cast
the whole show with relatively unknown
actors so that's kind of how I ended up
getting it I believe we spent seven
months in southern Africa and Namibia
Mozambique in in South Africa we didn't
have our families out there people
didn't have their girlfriends out there
it was just 40 dudes stuck in the desert
not to compare too closely to uh being
in the military but there's a lot of
hurry up and wait that's a lot of Suns
that's something you experience a lot in
both the military and on a movie set
because there's so many massive scenes
with tons of Humvees and you know just
to reset could take 45 minutes that
creates a very specific dynamic when
you're 40 dudes and you sit around
twelve hours a day just talking just you
know you make fun of each other of your
and it you know it creates a very just
you know a strong bond it goes a little
different we could all got killed today
[Music]
that one lady we're still a very tight
group we still see each other all the
time and hang out and I'm incredibly
privileged and proud to be a part of
that True Blood
well it's actually quite inching how I
ended up getting to rolled because I'd
met with Alan Ball the creator of the
show and then my agents got a phone call
five months into our shoot on Generation
Kill I he asked if I was interested and
I said absolutely but there's a slight
problem I'm in Maputo and I'm here for
another two months I'm shooting trying
to kill and Alan was have all that that
sucks because we're about to shoot this
in a month or so and we you know
unfortunately it looked like I was I was
gonna be able to do it then the writers
strike happened thank God for the
writers strike if you were already in
production in the scripts written you
were fine but the True Blood scripts
weren't written so they had to push I
was able to finish genders to kill in
Africa come back to LA for them to cast
Eric Northman so that's how it happened
even though I've a terrible memory I do
remember a lot of that show we it was
seven incredible years and what a ride
that was and the very first night was
special because it was the first time I
met Stephen Moyer and Kristin Bauer who
plays Pam my vampire daughter on the
show these were people that then became
some of my closest friends and but the
first night Kristen had just flown in
from the Philippines she'd done a movie
out there so she was all very jet-lagged
and nothing made sense and I was she was
very kooky and I was like what's going
on here and there's a shot of us walking
out of Fantasia and then Kristen and I
supposed to fly off and the way they
shot that was they put us on a
skateboard with a rope and started
pulling us and I knew that this is a big
show like they had some money but
they're pulling us on a skateboard
that's the visual effect so I was
slightly concerned
and then again she turned out to like a
lover more than anything and she's one
of my favorite people and somehow they
figured out a better way to make us fly
after that good night tiny humans
battleship well I've never done anything
like battleship before and I was just
intrigued to do something of that scope
I met with Pete Berg the director of a
bunch of times and I he was very
inspiring I just loved his energy and
his vision and and again it was just
kind of out of my comfort zone and it
was very different from the smaller
Indies I'd done before so I was quite
excited to go and do something big and a
bit more like like a tentpole action
film it's one thing if it's a backdrop
then it's it doesn't affect the acting
really but if you're gonna have an
emotional moment with an animal or a
human and that's it's a it's a tennis
ball on a c-stand it can be a bit more
challenging Legend of Tarzan we started
four months before principal photography
with Magnus my trainer and this was all
new to me I'd never worked with a
personal trainer before I'd never been
on a specific diet before so for three
months we I just ate a lot
it's basically 7,000 calories a day and
just bulk up I would lift weights not do
any cardio because I'm naturally quite
lean so if I did any cardio I lose
weight and then about six weeks before
we started shooting he would change the
diet and the training a bit to try to
get more lean so you would kind of hold
on to the muscle mass but get rid of any
any fat whatever happens it's not sin to
feel
understand mm-hmm I went a bit nuts
actually shot it in London and I
remember on Sundays my day off I would
walk around the area I I lived in and
just look into restaurants and look at
people eating it was one Italian
restaurant on the corner I just like
would stand outside and look in like as
the ringing pizza and pasta and stuff
and I'd be like oh one day one day I'll
get to eat that on Tarzan the sets were
real but the animals weren't so that was
some stunt man in a jumpsuit I believe
that was the first day we met so we met
on set shook hands and then went down on
all fours and started rubbing each other
[Music]
for a bonding experience literally big
little eyes very very intense but such a
well-written character he's a an abusive
husband but not written in a
stereotypical way there's a lot of depth
to the character and I also love the way
he was introduced you kind of liked this
guy hopefully in the beginning of the
show and he's a great dad and he's great
with Celeste his wife they have a very
strong beautiful connection and then
slowly you start to see that there's
another side to him and there's a
darkness there and something he that he
genuinely is struggling with
huh you're hurting me oh I'm hurting you
it was so interesting to kind of explore
that because that's how you make it
interesting for the audience I believe I
think we have a tendency to cut we're
naturally organically quite lazy and we
want to sit back specially when we watch
television or movies we make it easy for
ourselves to go like okay I got a good
guy bad guy because most stories are
quite generic that way it's fun if you
can introduce a character in a nice and
charming way and get the audience to
like him and then they start to question
that and like wait a minute I kind of
like this guy and now he does this and
most people are conflicted and they have
a practical side but there's also
darkness there
I think it's that dichotomy that creates
a you know a real interesting character
pull the dark I've had the best time on
hold the dark I think Jeremy Sonier the
filmmaker is one of one of the greatest
filmmakers out there he's got a very
unique eye and Sensibility and the
script is it's based on a novel that I
love it's such a dark rich disturbing
world the character is unlike anything
I've ever played before there's a
profound darkness there it loses a child
and then he sets out to avenge the death
of his son and nothing can stop him that
trajectory and that kind of that
determination was quite wonderful to
explore it takes place in Alaska a
little bit in Afghanistan or Iraq when
you first meet my character but the rest
of it takes place in Alaska we shot it
and Oliver it up in the woods last
winter so that was a great experience
because we were out there and it was
freezing cold and just added a lot of
texture to the to the story you're the
one for my lawyer yes
you raise the dead
I have no questions were hidden well it
was a very intense shoot the guys had
done a three minutes short that I saw
and I thought it was really good and
then I met them and they were late 20s
at the time but I could tell that they
were they had something very unique they
were very very smart and they knew
exactly what they had they wanted to
tell the story and were heavily
influenced by early Spielberg and that
kind of that visual language it was a
tough shoot because it's basically three
characters in a basement for 85% of the
movie it's Andrea Riseborough plays the
mother and not the dad and it's about a
couple and their daughter hiding a
post-apocalyptic movie about a family
hiding a bomb shelter and then there's a
twist towards the end but it was it was
a tough one cuz how to lose weight for
it so I was kind of running on fumes for
two months I was always starving and to
try to look emaciated and I had very
little energy and we were in this dark
basement and there was like a fire going
off and it was like rats running around
and kids crying it was just like a lot
of dark medicine but they are incredible
and I couldn't be more thrilled for them
today with their success with with
strangers things because they they
deserve it there are hard-working guys
and incredibly talented a little drummer
girl show the little drummer girl is a
six-part limited series it's based on a
Johnny Kerr a novel and directed by Park
chan-wook Korean filmmaker did the old
boy trilogy and handmaiden Stoker I've
been obsessed with the old boy trilogy
since I was a teenager I think there are
extraordinary films this was kind of
like when I got the call from Larsson
tree or this was another one where I
basically said yes before even reading
it a young girl the British actors goes
to Greece on vacation she meets a guy on
this island and he suddenly invites her
on this little trip to the mainland to
go to Athens and go for a little Drive
for a couple of days drive around Greece
she's like well this could be a cool
adventure and then she discovers that
his
intentions are far from romantic he's
actually a a spy that's kind of how the
story kicks off